lo que quiero introducir en este vídeo
es la idea de la cruz que inician en la
cruz que inician esta es una de las
herramientas de análisis del pensamiento
keynesiano que pues simplemente es la
idea de que de vez en cuando el producto
interno bruto puede estar en equilibrio
pero no en su nivel óptimo que está
operando muy por debajo de su potencial
y la forma en la cual podemos claro
siguiendo un punto de vista que
iniciando la forma en la cual podemos
llevarlo a su nivel óptimo es de alguna
forma afectando la demanda agregada lo
que vamos a hacer ahorita es que vamos a
construir nuestro análisis de la cruz
keynesiana basado en lo que ya
aprendimos acerca de la función de
consumo entonces primero vamos a empezar
a pensar acerca del gasto planeado vale
vamos a ver qué sucede cuando el gasto
planeado pues que era distinto de la
producción real de los gastos que
realmente se hicieron entonces por acá
esto es muy similar a lo que ya hicimos
solo que en términos de planeación vale
entonces tenemos gastos planeados gastos
planeados simplemente podemos escribir
los componentes del gasto agregado
entonces tenemos el gasto del consumidor
luego tenemos inversión y aquí tengo que
ser un poco cuidadoso es inversión
planea
estoy acá es exactamente lo que las
compañías están esperando producir y la
razón por la cual hago la distinción es
porque si por alguna razón
el gasto agregado es menor de lo que se
esperaba entonces se van a crear
inventarios esos inventarios se
encontrarían como una inversión entonces
estaría por arriba del inventario
planeado vale por otro lado si la
demanda es más alta de lo que se
esperaba puede ser que los inventarios
se empiecen a agotar y entonces hay que
quitarle un poco a la inversión planeada
o sea básicamente estaríamos comiendo
nos parte de la inversión total y
tendríamos que hacer ese cambio
bueno esfuerzo tenemos que hacer la
distinción entre la inversión planeada y
la verdadera inversión y luego por
supuesto tenemos el gasto gubernamental
y finalmente tenemos la exportación neta
y bueno ahorita para el análisis que
vamos a hacer de cruz que inician a otra
vez esta es una simplificación muy
grande vamos a suponer que en cualquier
nivel de producto interno bruto o bien
producción agregada todo esto ya que es
constante que estas de acá no dependen
de la producción o bien del producto
interno bruto que claro que es una gran
simplificación verdad o sea que si
grafica mos cualquiera de estas en
términos
en términos del ingreso agregado
entonces se van a ver como una línea
horizontal entonces a lo mejor la
inversión planeada se vería se vería
algo como así a lo mejor el gasto
gubernamental algo así claro estamos
otra vez suponiendo todo esto de acá
verdad a lo mejor estamos exagerando un
poco estamos diciendo que es un factor
externo y entonces estamos suponiendo
que es fijo que no depende de la demanda
agregada entonces el gasto gubernamental
se ve así y el exportación neta algo de
este estilo el factor que si va a estar
afectado y hará un corte lo puedes
imaginar porque dije que trabajaríamos
sobre la función del consumo pero el
factor que si está afectado por el
ingreso agregado es el gasto del
consumidor esto de acá entonces la forma
en la cual esta cosa se vería la forma
en la cual se vería déjame déjame
dibujar otra gráfica por acá
entonces voy a dibujarla por acá
entonces tenemos aquí abajo ingreso
agregado esta es la variable
independiente y luego por acá podemos
ver esto como gasto gasto va entonces
sin nada más gráfica mos el gasto del
consumidor es algo que ya vimos verdad
sobre todo suponiendo una función de
consumo lineal como las que estudiamos
en los vídeos pasado todas eran lineales
y había unas distintas sin embargo todas
deberían más o menos algo de este estilo
teniendo una intersección positiva con
el eje vertical y luego tenían una
pendiente hacia arriba que era menor que
1 entonces el consumo por sí mismo se
vería algo así esto sería el gasto del
consumidor en función y en función del
ingreso agregado y luego si sumáramos
todas estas constantes de acá entonces
la gráfica para el gasto planeado
agregado se vería algo así por ejemplo
si nomás ponemos la exportación neta se
ve un poquito más arriba porque es
constante en cada punto agregamos esto
después con el gobierno se va a más para
arriba y con todo más o menos
acabaríamos lo voy a poner con otro
color
entonces acabaríamos con algo que se
vería más o menos así entonces
simplemente estoy empezando con el gasto
del consumidor
claro suponiendo que la función de
consumo es lineal verdad que no
necesariamente hay que hacerlo así pero
hace que el análisis de la cruz que
inicia na se vea más como una cruz y más
fácil de analizar pero bueno luego todas
esas cosas constantes las estamos
sumando y desplazan de esta línea hasta
por acá es el gasto planeado agrega muy
bien ahora sabemos sabemos a partir del
flujo circular de la economía que cuando
una economía está en equilibrio entonces
la producción agregada es igual al gasto
agregado o bien que el gasto agregado es
igual al ingreso agregado entonces
realmente cuando estamos en equilibrio
estas dos cosas van a ser iguales y de
hecho podemos trazar una línea donde
están todos los puntos donde eso es
igual entonces sería una línea que
esencialmente tiene pendiente de uno en
donde ya siempre es igual al gasto
entonces se verían se vería más o menos
más o menos como algo así y aquí es de
donde viene el nombre de cruz keynesiana
porque básicamente tenemos el gasto
planeado y por acá tenemos la línea de
equilibrio bueno a lo que yo le llamo la
línea de equilibrio porque son los
puntos en donde el ingreso es igual al
gasto por acá el ingreso es igual al
gasto el ingreso es igual al gasto
entonces cuando vemos el gasto planeado
agregado que también se puede pensar
como la demanda agregada en función del
ingreso agregado este punto de acá es el
punto en el cual la economía está en
equilibrio donde los gastos son de hecho
iguales los gastos son iguales a la
producción verdad de hecho aquí está un
poquito hecho de ccoo en realidad pues
debería de parecerse más como a un
cuadrado déjame ver si lo puedo arreglar
un poco lo voy a borrar para que se vea
como una línea de 45 grados entonces en
realidad se debería de ver con una línea
de 45 grados más o menos así eso se ve
un poco mejor
entonces ese punto de ahí es en donde
estamos en equilibrio sabes que esto no
va a estar padre porque después voy a
hacer un análisis y va a ser más difícil
hacerlo pero bueno creo que es la idea
es la línea donde el ingreso es igual
entonces lo voy a dibujar así para que
el punto quede más fácil de analizar va
ahora aquí es donde el análisis de la
cruz keynesiana se empieza a convertir
en una herramienta más interesante
porque podemos empezar a pensar qué
sucede en ciertas situaciones va
entonces estoy acá para qué es el
equilibrio un nivel de equilibrio del
producto interno bruto pero qué
sucedería si por alguna razón el ingreso
agregado es mayor que ese nivel de
equilibrio vamos a pensar en ese caso
qué sucede supongamos que estamos por
acá lo voy a poner en color rosa
mexicano por acá a este punto vamos a
llamarle 1 y qué sucede aquí qué sucede
en esta situación en que uno pues por
acá la producción agregada que es lo
mismo que el inglés agregado está como
por esta altura pero estoy acá es el
gasto planeado verdad entonces pues todo
este exceso de acá todo este exceso que
está por arriba de la demanda planeada
pues esencialmente van a ser inventarios
que se están acumulando la economía está
produciendo más de lo que realmente
necesita los inventarios se acumulan y
entonces las compañías no están
vendiendo todos sus productos
exceso de inventario siempre se refleja
en la inversión y en este caso este
delta este delta se tendría que agregar
a la inversión planeada y con eso
podríamos ver cuánto es la inversión
total ok si la economía está en ese
estado entonces las compañías dicen no
sabes que estamos produciendo demasiados
están haciendo muchas inversiones
tenemos que disminuir la producción y
entonces hay una retroalimentación
natural para que el producto interno
bruto regrese a su punto de equilibrio y
ahora qué sucede si estamos por debajo
del punto de equilibrio no sé supongamos
que el producto interno bruto está por
aquí vamos a ponerle dos en vez de
ponerle súper índice debería de ponerle
subíndice vale entonces vamos a llamarle
y2 entonces por acá por acá la demanda
agregada en este nivel de producción es
más de lo que realmente se produce la
gente necesita más más bienes y
servicios entonces aquí tenemos un
déficit de producción y esto muestra que
la gente va a empezar a consumir se los
inventarios así muy rápidamente
la inversión inicial no fue suficiente o
bien otra forma de decirlo es que los
inventarios
no sé por ejemplo si yo tuviera un
puesto de limonada y siempre tuviera
cinco vasos de limonadas en mi
inventario porque sé que se vende un
vaso por hora y de repente se me
empiezan a vender dos vasos por hora
entonces mi inventario se va a empezar a
agotar y aquí se está reflejando esto la
producción la producción está por debajo
de lo que se demanda cuando las
compañías ven que esto sucede dicen uy
no no no yo no quiero que se me acaben
mis bienes y servicios voy a producir
más claro cuando hablo de inventarios
habló más de bienes que de servicios
entonces van a producir más y de nuevo
la producción se va a ir naturalmente
hacia el equilibrio espero que lo que
haya dicho tenga más o menos sentido en
los siguientes vídeos vamos a usar la
cruz keynesiana para pensar bueno con el
pensamiento keynesiano como el cambio de
algunos de estos factores puede afectar
el nuevo nivel de equilibrio del
producto interno bruto